Wow you recognize the voice actress
singer superstar that's Bette Midler of
course she's revealing how she prepared
for her Broadway return she stars in the
very popular revival of Hello Dolly
she's redesigned the world to fit her
very unique personality her
show-stopping performance earned her a
Tony nomination thank you very much you
spoke with her yesterday for CBS Sunday
morning at the Shubert theater here in
New York City we talked about when she
first fell in love with the stage do you
remember the first time you came to
Broadway and saw a musical that made you
sit and go wow I can and want to do that
well I came to do Broadway musicals from
Hawaii from Hawaii I had been in the
community theater as a kid 14 years old
was fired for my first show and why
because I upstaged the lead okay note to
self don't do that yeah well I learned a
good lesson well I didn't really know
that that's what I was doing but I found
out that that was not a no-no and I was
fired instantly and I knew that it was
what I wanted to do i from the font firm
from the first time I saw a theatrical
production which was in the Honolulu
Community Theatre at Fort Rutgers I knew
that that's what I wanted to do because
here we're all these it was a light that
I had never seen before it was a light
and everyone under it looks so beautiful
I just it was different from real life
and it was like a dream and I wanted to
be in that dream when you look at that
girl back then who was singing gonna
look back you you never do never look
back no never look back never look back
because if you're looking back you can't
go look forward you can't go forward
that is a point you can see the full
interview with Bette Midler this weekend
on CBS Sunday March 6th at but speaking
of looking cheat look spent doesn't she
Charlie Charlie
71 guys she has pink streaks in her hair
anything I liked our house she says
everybody's putting color in your hair
she said go to Ricky's a beauty supply
you can do it I love it looking forward
Butler he's awesome can't wait for that